first time i encountered norm was when
he did stand up
on our late night show
really early on
do you remember how that happened yes i
do it was uh
a month after we started it was october
of 93
and a guest dropped out
as
it would happen back then oh yeah people
were people were back in october of 93
we had been on the air a month
um
believe it or not it wasn't going well
ladies and gentlemen no one
no one thought we would last 28 minutes
let alone 28 years but uh they were
dropping like flashlights but but guests
were dropping out
at the last second constantly and so
someone dropped out and and what'd you
do so i i had worked with norm a year
earlier on the dennis miller show which
didn't last very long but he you know
was the fun anybody who had met him even
for a minute knew he's the funniest guy
in the world uh sorry conan but you know
he is just a force dennis dennis miller
you're talking about now
you're not making it clear
you said he he worked on the dennis
miller show he always understood i
thought it was understood i thought he
was talking about science gallery i like
dennis but come on uh dennis is funny
too
it's unbelievable he's a so you knew
that you knew him right and i knew he
had just worked he got a job as a writer
on saturday live so in a pinch i went
you know i went up there i thought he
would do it and i knew you know usually
you work with a stand-up to hone a set
but with norm i didn't need to i wasn't
worried at all i i knew that afternoon
he would come on the air and kill and he
did
he annihilated and he did a bit about
buying a dog
which was so funny um
and that was the first time he did our
show and that was 28 years ago right
um and then he he came on
many times after that
and
i i been thinking about what is it
what is it that made this guy
so
insanely different from everyone else
and and i had this recollection
that andy you said something once
which was and i always remembered it
it was after a norm segment and norm had
annihilated he had done really well as
he always did
and you said to me
um that guy
doesn't care in a way that frightens me
and what you meant was
uh
he
he had this seeming like indifference
about whether the crowd liked it or not
he was going to do what he was going to
do and he was so ballsy that you found
it kind of scary and i knew exactly what
you were talking about
it was always a high wire act
and one of the things i remember most
about um
norm is i would start laughing
the minute he came out yeah uh of the
curtain so i'd say let's zoom in nor
mcdonald and he would come out
and
he had this look in his eye
this glint in his eye and i was laughing
before he said anything yeah and
i will attest and you know you will back
me up on this both of you can back me up
on this
i always wanted to be a uh host who
uh helped
um help the guest as much as i could
it's called host yeah yeah but but but
what i what i would do as you know
sometimes i'd be hearing something that
wasn't that funny but i i learned you
know how to be a generous laugher for
people if it would help right i have
always said to people if you want to
really see me laugh and this is long
before norm passed
if you really want to see what it looks
like yeah when i am laughing watch a
normal mcdonald's segment because
um
i have my hands on my belly which i
think might be my tail like i i put my
hands on my stomach and i
i would have my hands on my stomach
sometimes just as norm is coming out
around the curtain and i see that crazy
look in his eye and that that insane
grin that he had with those sort of like
round apple cheeks
he was a mischievous kid and he was out
to cause trouble and he's coming around
the bend and his eye would catch me and
he'd always look a little surprised to
see me even though i had just introduced
him of course and you've just seen him
five minutes i had just seen him five
minutes before
but oh my god and and uh
and i think there was this
um people get you know cynical about
show business and and rightfully they
think well it's all set up or it's all
been contrived and sometimes it has been
but
but with that guy
when you look at any of these clips
you're watching us
be just as stunned yeah as the audiences
because we don't know yeah we don't know
what's going to happen yeah
i think well
one of the things to me like
like norm was so canadian like he was
like deeply deeply polite deeply deeply
concerned
with
the person that he's talking to an
audience not so much but but a person
that he's talking to
because even like the the famous clip of
like
uh you know that and now and it's you
know and it's arguably one of the
biggest things circulating now about
lauren erdogan about uh norm is
when he was on with courtney thorne
smith yeah and was making fun of
carrot top but he wasn't making fun of
courtney thorne smith right he was
having fun with her but he still was
kind of
taking care of her in a way and having
fun with you yeah um
so he i think he had this like sort of
very and i mean i just i showed my
sister texted me the day after he died
and she said do you remember i was at
the show i was maybe 18 years old and i
was in your office you weren't there you
were rehearsing or meeting or something
and norah macdonald walked in and i
introduced myself and he sat down and
talked to me for an hour and asked me
questions about myself and
you know and and made me laugh a lot and
she said nobody
in your business has done that
before or since right right and and that
was that was one aspect of norm was like
an incredibly kind considerate listener
but then there's also this stripe of
norm that is a destroyer
and it is not it's not a coincidence
that when we talk about him yeah it's
not he annihilated he killed he
destroyed yeah
and what norm was drawn to touch points
that you're not supposed to touch
and norm would not only touch them he
would dry hump them yeah you know he
would just and and so
in a talk show context you have this guy
for whom nothing is sacred and in fact
there's a little bit like you don't
sense aggression from him
except when you get to like
hypocrisy or something that's you know
phoniness yeah and he was also you know
he was also too not afraid
publicly or in private or something to
let people that he felt were not funny
who were being paid to be funny let them
know he didn't think they were funny
yeah and that's because he had so much
genius he took it he took it i mean
yeah he took it comedy very seriously